more protests and community meeting with
lawmakers are planned in Sacramento
today over the police shooting death of
Stephon Clark John Blackstone is at
Sacramento City Hall with more on this
story John good morning good morning
well one question likely to come up when
protesters are here and when the City
Council holds a public meeting on
Clark's death today is why officers
turned off their body cam video minutes
after shooting Clark now on Monday
Clark's grandmother was here she
described what she heard in her backyard
as police opened fire Stephon Clark's
grandmother stood with national civil
rights leaders Monday and said she
feared for her own safety when she heard
gunfire behind her hug her grandson was
killed in a hail of gunfire captured on
police body cam video minutes after the
shooting officers put their body cameras
on mute so their conversations were not
recorded that has raised suspicion it
sure has
Sacramento mayor Darrell Steinberg says
he wants to know why are there any
circumstances under the training
protocols that make that justified Clark
had been spotted by a sheriff's
helicopter and was suspected of breaking
car windows in the area two patrol
officers pursued him and within seconds
of reaching him opened fire they feared
he had a gun in his hand it was only a
cell phone police civil rights attorney
Ben Crump who previously worked with
families of shooting victims Trayvon
Martin and Michael Brown is now
representing the Stefan Clark family and
we will fight for Stefan and can we get
justice for Stefan
krump also said there will be an
independent autopsy on crumbs on Clark's
body his funeral is set for Thursday
Anthony John Blackstone thanks John